[Musica]
Ma perché
Ma quando mi daranno da mangiare
Fatemi mangiare schiera Ma dai che stai
dicendo schiavi schiavi quali schiavi
che cosa stai dicendo tu che cosa stai
dicendo Ma io non ho detto niente
per una volta
[Musica]
Ma la smetti di sussurrare queste cose
ma che cosa stai dicendo Non sto
sussurrando proprio un bel niente ma
stai sentendo le voci per caso
No vabbè niente forse deve essere stato
quel frullato strano che mi hai fatto
bere
[Musica]
te la faccio sul letto
bene si chiama se non mi fai uscire ti
faccio la pipì sul letto
avete sentito anche voi
[Musica]
non ci riesco
è come se sentissi i pensieri di Circe O
forse lei sta comunicando con me in
qualche modo strano non le senti anche
tu ma io veramente non sento un bel
niente Ma sei sicura di star bene
Veramente No in realtà
credo di stare molto bene Deve essere
stato quel frullato che hai deciso di
fare prendendo la ricetta di fiamma lo
sapevo non è mai una buona idea quando
Vitale prepara qualcosa ma io volevo
preparare solo qualcosa di buono da
mangiare poi c'era la banana pensavo
fosse una ricetta classica di un
frullato non lo sapevo che fiamma avesse
messo dentro tutti quegli ingredienti
per fare poi una pozione cosa che potevo
sapere io ecco
ho trovato anch'io dobbiamo trovare una
soluzione prima che la trasformazione
vada avanti e poi succederà come è
successo con te che cambiano personalità
e magari vorrò mangiarti Quindi è meglio
che trovi una soluzione subito anzi
controlliamo subito in questo diario di
fiamma
stai zitta un momento non riesco a
concentrarmi
Allora la ricetta dell'ululata e qualche
idea tu Eh guarda però cioè nel senso io
non sarei così tanto preoccupato perché
alla fine io l'ho bevuto tutto il
frullato e quindi è normale che mi sono
trasformato tu ne hai bevuto davvero
poco quindi non penso che questa pozione
sia così potente da farti leggere o
sentire i pensieri di Circe Beh in
realtà che il motivo potrebbe essere
Siccome io ho bevuto pochissimo pozione
non
mi sono tardo
Oh quella pozione non era poi
trasformarsi ma è per sentire i pensieri
degli animali e poter comunicare con gli
animali vediamo
allora che ho fatto bene ha preparato
quella pozione Così almeno ho realizzato
anche un tuo sogno Poi dimmi che non
sono perfetto c'è un modo per scoprirlo
se chiamiamo Merlino e vediamo se riesco
a sentire anche i pensieri di Merlino
Merli
se n'è andato
e puoi aiutarmi a chiamare Merlino
Se lo volete Chiamatelo voi Io sto
benissimo senza di lui
allora Merlino devi capire una cosa io
ho bevuto una pozione voglio capire se
riesco a comunicare con te
Sì grazie per la zampa Ma senti Allora
dimmi qualcosa
Sì puoi parlarmi Parlami
[Musica]
era quello che dico Merlino no non
riesco a capire Merlino non riesco a
sentire i suoi pensieri come concirce
quindi non era una pozione per capire
gli animali purtroppo
Uffa
Peccato Mi sarebbe piaciuto saper
parlare con gli animali Ma quindi che
cos'è allora mi trasformerò anch'io cosa
succederà e succederà che magari Nella
peggiore delle ipotesi oltre ad
ascoltare Circe magari di trasformerai
in gatto che poi non è che è una cosa
così grave i gatti sono carini sono
pucciosi
[Musica]
ho capito tutto mettiti qui seduto
adesso ci penso io perché praticamente
penso che
stavi per trasformarti in viaggio ma
dietro di serio non ti preoccupare No no
no adesso certo subito una soluzione
vedi già ti piacciono le coccole come i
gatti proprio visto tu stai qui io vado
a cercare una soluzione magari durante
tutto per bloccare questa trasformazione
che ovviamente cercare questa soluzione
e guarda già mi è venuto un paio di idee
dove cercarle fuori già le idee molto
chiare Anzi Hahaha
Ok ragazzi mi è venuta l'idea
praticamente la pozione diceva che c'era
bisogno del fiore puzzone vi ricordate E
quindi se ci voleva una cosa molto
puzzolente so bene io dove trovarla
vedete Seguitemi andiamo
[Musica]
che cosa stai facendo Anita
No non si graffia il divano non si
graffia quello che voglio Aspetta guarda
ho portato dal titolo il fiore puzzone
lo senti
funziona sta funzionando vedi
di graffiato non mi interessa trovare
nessuna soluzione Lasciami in pace
voglio dormire cosa
mangiare
di nuovo forse io la soluzione Devo
trovare qualcosa di più puzzolente e
credo di averla proprio qui
[Musica]
Ma cosa cosa puoi fare con quella che
respira
[Applauso]
Pensavo peggio in realtà
pensavi peggio
Questa è una sfida e io accetto questo
tipo
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sono un po' stanco Sono dovuto scappare
Anita sta peggiorando E sta peggiorando
anche tanto credo che a breve si
trasformerà Ma l'avete capito anche voi
che cosa dovrò fare adesso come
soluzione vero chiamare quel personaggio
che inizia con la L e finisce con l'ex e
per fortuna che ho qui con me il libro
per poter chiamare l'ex Com'è che
bisognava fare per chiamare l'ex Apri il
libro Gira due volte
Ok poi Chiudi il libro e lui apparirà
Vitale Ciao hai fatto un atterraggio più
o meno poco morbido ma di nuovo mi
chiami di nuovo Sì c'è stato giusto un
piccolissimo problema con Anita avevo
bisogno del tuo aiuto Ah Ci risiamo non
riesco mai a farmi un bagno nella
spiaggia ma perché perché ci devi
aiutare qual è il problema è come dire
aiuta Sì si sta comportando in maniera
strana praticamente ti ricordi quella
pozione che avevo fatto l'altra volta
vero Certo che me la ricordo che mi si è
trasformato in un lupo mannaro con la
panna Ti ha tirato uno schiaffo di panna
e tu poi ti si eri trasformato in Vitale
perché c'era il peperoncino Sì è giusto
Ecco adesso il problema è che Anita
credo si stia trasformando il gatto
in che in un gatto Sì in un gatto perché
ci avevo messo i piedi di circa nella
pozione ti ricordi no aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta ragioniamo un secondo
ragioniamoci fermo un attimo Sì tu eri
un lupo mannaro sì
e mi ricordo che nel libro c'erano due
formule Sì e tu avevi preso i peli di
Merlino Esatto
i peli di Circe giusto giustissimo non è
possibile no
Cosa c'è che non va Alex
Anita si sta per trasformare in gatto
mannaro
la mia vita
fammi lo squillo Alex che cosa stai
dicendo Ti ho chiamato perché mi devi
aiutare
sei davvero paura di un gatto quei due
che fifone
Ti ho chiamato apposta perché mi devi
aiutare quella vita Mi hai pure detto
che si sta trasformando il gatto mannaro
No no io non ti posso aiutare con il
gatto mannaro non ti posso aiutare
perché non mi puoi aiutare Sei una
creatura grande e forte Io sono un
mostrologo io conosco le creature E ti
posso assicurare che sei un lupo mannaro
da una scala da 1 a 10 è almeno 8 ok
come pericolo Come ferocia come come
difficoltà Capito E quindi un gatto
mannaro quanto sarà 6 4 e mezzo 65 Oh di
65 che cosa stai dicendo l'ex
è l'unica creatura che ha l'intelligenza
astuzia ferocia è troppo forte tutto
questo e tu non sei così astuto
intelligente per oggi no tu sei buono
non riusciresti a combatterla cercare di
riportarla normale Vitale io non
combatto le creature io le studio ma
adesso l'ex che cosa facciamo no no no
no non mi chiedere che cosa facciamo che
cosa è su noi come non mi aiuti No no no
io me ne ritorno in spiaggia a farmi il
mio bagnetto ok È tutta la vedrai con
Anita trasformate da gatto mannaro Alla
fine l'hai fatto tu il problema e te lo
risolvi ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao
E adesso che cosa faccio l'ex se n'è
andato dice che ha paura dei gatti e dei
gatti mannari e certo che è un po'
fifone per essere un lupo La cosa
positiva è che forse Anita è tornata
normale quindi io tornerei in casa e
magari per essere sicuro mi chiudo a
chiave in una stanza così non c'è
problema Ok io vado
a nascondere mi devo nascondere
qui siamo al sicuro
credo che qui se entravi bene
anche qui non ci sto
bene
tanto vanità
sono tornata normale no
c'era qualcosa qui ho sentito il rumore
pure lo continuo a sentire qua
ah ah ah
Ah
[Musica]
sei pronto ad essere mangiato Vitale
ad essere mangiato
cosa stai dicendo Anita Ti sono spuntata
delle orecchie là sopra in testa
preparati e diventa
una strizzatino di Vitale
Io non sono non sono buona da mangiare
Guarda sono piuttosto sono piuttosto
amaro Amaro
è molto molto poco faticoso aiuto
[Applauso]
la porta chiusa stai cercando Questa
sì sto cercando quella non è che me la
lanceresti per favore basta che me la
lancio non ti devi per forza avvicinare
davvero Va bene va bene
devi avvicinarti tu a prendere la chiave
vieni qua non ti faccio niente vieni qua
dai avvicinati
[Musica]
già non ti faccio niente
Sì sì guarda sono solo un piccolo
gattino intendo Te lo giuro non ti
faccio niente
Io guarda la prendo la chiave la chiave
la prendo Però tu mi devi promettere che
non mi farai del male hai capito Anche
perché mi stai guardando con quegli
occhi lì che non mi sembrano che ci sia
tanto del bene Lì sì sì sì Stai calma
Stai calma Io la prendo Però tu non mi
farai del male Ok vedi l'ho presa e tu
non mi stai facendo del male non mi
farai mica del male Vedi io mi sto
allontanando per andare ad aprire la
porta e tu non mi stai facendo del male
Giusto bravo
Ma come mai quando io mi giro tu ti
avvicini sempre di più ma non mi sto
avvicinando
[Musica]
dai immobile Anzi no perché sei troppo
pesante da trasportare cammina dove vado
Non mi fare male con questo unghiattolo
dove posso metterlo
non devi disturbare i miei piani da
gatto mannaro quindi
ho un'idea anche un'idea ti ridò la
chiave e tu mi lasci in pace va bene non
mi lasci scappare Non mi interessa della
chiave
anzi meglio togliertela non si sa mai
che ti mangi anche questo
video no troppo tardi cammina
vai
in trappola e l'ho chiuso fuori nel
terrazzo di certo non può saltare giù
perché non può saltare come noi gatti
dall'alto è
Semplicemente devo continuare i miei
video